foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
look who we have here Mr shiny and new
hey what's up uh why do you sound
sarcastic no no we're we're just joking
it looks just like Greg welcome back we
were wondering if we'd see you again
what do you mean again I'm brand new I
just came out look at this what is he
talking about I think it was that
software update Craig we know it's you
no I said I'm brand new my my name is
Tim what are you oh God you got me there
Craig very funny very good he still
loves me who is Steve still loves me
Steve still loves me Steve still loves
me oh my God
new homepod old homepod okay new homepod
got it so this new home pod the second
generation homepod that's just come out
is one of the most confusing new Apple
products I've seen in a long time we
just reviewed the 10th generation iPad
which was already pretty weird but this
one is incredible so just a little
history recap for context so the
original homepod came out in 2018. it
was a 350 dollar Siri enabled smart
speaker with excellent sound really
impressive engineering Rock Solid build
quality and a non-removable cable it
kind of flopped and not a lot of people
bought it Apple then decided to lower
the price a bit from 350 to 300 which
they almost never do so that's a pretty
good sign of how well things were doing
apparently it peaked at around six
percent of Home Smart speaker market
share which honestly is higher than I
would have thought and eventually they
caved and came out with a homepod mini a
much smaller version of basically the
same exact thing but now it's 99 bucks
this one started selling much better for
obvious reasons and eventually the big
homepod was just deleted from their site
in 2021 it was discontinued but now it's
back
it's new and improved it's but it's it's
like didn't you try this already I mean
I should say this is to be fair it is a
better product in a couple small ways
it's kind of hard to tell just by
looking at it from the outside but
here's what's actually new fundamentally
it's the same layout in almost the same
size you can see slightly different
proportions here the new one is a little
bit more Stout I guess you could say and
while we're at it this is actually a new
color which is called Midnight instead
of the original space gray you might
remember the name from The Midnight
iPhone color which is mostly black but
with the tiniest hint of blue and that
is here too then up top the touch
surface is roughly the same size but
it's inset a little bit this time and
the display covers the whole circle
instead of just a small portion in the
middle so anytime you're talking to it
or adjusting the volume or talking to
Siri a little it's just a little more
vibrant up there and then they've also
clearly listened to some of the feedback
because the power cable is now fully
removable designed to be removed unlike
the last one so you can feed it up
behind a desk or a table or something
when you're setting it up but also do
you remember that weird story where the
original homepods white plastic bottom
was staining wooden tables we confirmed
it with our own it would only take like
one to two minutes of sitting on a
wooden table doing absolutely nothing
for it to leave a permanent white ring
on that table naturally we tried the
same thing with the new one which does
have a bit of a redesigned base to
spread out that surface area
and it takes longer but it actually
still does stain with a slightly
different pattern but it does in fact
still stain wooden tables this is your
PSA if you get the white home pod do not
expect it to not stain your table what
else oh inside there are two new sensors
there's a temperature sensor and a
humidity sensor which is nice to have
hey Siri what's the temperature
it's currently 49 degrees
that's outside hey Siri what's the
temperature in here
it's 71 degrees Fahrenheit in the office
and so you can sort of like calibrate
that to sync up with our smart home
actions let's say the humidity gets
below a certain number you turn on your
smart humidifier or your temperature
gets over 75 degrees you turn on your
fan your AC stuff like that it's cool to
have it built in instead of needing a
separate sensor like I have with my
Google home setup and there's also a new
sound recognition feature so if homepod
with its microphones here's an alarm or
a smoke detector or something like that
it'll send a notification to your phone
which obviously doesn't make sense if
you're home but if you're away and a
smoke detector goes off and you get a
notification on your phone you will now
know to check the cameras in your home
or something like that to see what's
going on good to know I should also
mention though that the 99 homepod mini
that I mentioned earlier also already
secretly had those sensors and they're
being activated by the latest homepod
software update along with the sound
recognition feature and matter support
it's the new homepod and mini actually
have a thread radio which means they can
be used as a matter hub but there is now
that matter support across the board
really the biggest change though is
actually what they've removed so we
talked about the homepod being a feat of
audio engineering in this little compact
package if you took a cross section of
the original homepod you'd see a woofer
on Top seven tweeters all the way around
the outside playing in every direction
and then six far-field microphones
in this new homepod this midnight
homepod here you'd actually have the
same woofer but you now have five
tweeters around the outside and four
far-field microphones so they removed
two tweeters removed two microphones and
removed fifty dollars from the price tag
so on one hand I guess I should be
impressed that it still sounds every bit
as good to me as the original despite
lesser internal Hardware now typical
disclaimer I'm no audio file but I've
listened to a lot of good speakers in my
time and after some quality time with
the homepod yeah it still sounds really
good it still has this super crisp and
balanced and not distorted sound in a
variety of environments and a variety of
volumes which is really important you
still get that satisfying thump from the
woofer and the low sub bass Rumble even
at lower volumes which is awesome and it
uses computational audio to adjust the
sound based on how close it is to a wall
so if you're plugging it into an outlet
you're probably kind of close to a wall
it figures out its location with the
shape shape of the room is and adjust
from there and you can put two together
for a stereo pair that puts out sound
much bigger than it looks like it's
supposed to it can even actually give
you full Dolby Atmos setup here they
actually they keep showing these setups
of it being your TV speakers and every
time I see this it looks silly because
it's like okay you got these you got six
hundred dollars of speakers here for a
300 TV and I'm not sure if this is a
real setup that exists anywhere but
honestly they sound good enough that in
a smaller room you really could get away
with this and no subwoofer they sound
that good so it's impressive it's a feat
of audio engineering like I said
but on the other hand
so is the last one and this is basically
the same exact proposition that flopped
on its face before it's still an
expensive premium audio product with
Siri I got we were just talking about
ratings on the waveform podcast recently
I'll link that episode below the like
button if you want to watch it but
basically the the thing about products
like this is It's hard to give it like a
number rating because it is a really
good product and a really bad product at
the same time like both are true like if
you're just buying it to be a speaker
for your iPhone and Apple music it's
really good it's it's the best one
clearly it's got incredible sound
quality the versatility of going
anywhere in the room and still sounding
good the quick pairing and beaming
feature with your iPhone the far field
mics can hear you pretty much at any
volume from across the room but this is
still a bad smart speaker like it still
won't set Spotify as its default music
app it still cannot pair to anything
that's not an iPhone or something with
AirPlay and it cannot be used as a pure
Bluetooth speaker there's still no audio
jack it still doesn't have a screen that
can actually tell you anything or
display background things like running
timers and at the end of the day it's
still a Series Speaker which means I
mean I did a whole video on Siri versus
Google Assistant versus the others but
just to keep it simple Siri is still
very limited and pretty bad so it's the
same as the it's going to flop again
right like is fixing the non-removable
speaker going to be the reason why this
doesn't flop no is the larger better
display on the top going to be the
reason the homepod is suddenly a success
no is the 50 price drop Gonna Save it
it's it's good but it's not massive it's
still super expensive the thing that we
learned with the homepod when it came
out
and we kind of knew this already but as
people don't really for the most part
like paying a huge premium just for
sound quality and that's why the mini
came out and was functionally the same
product but didn't sound as good and
that sold way more because it was
cheaper maybe Apple just doesn't care
anymore they spent the money developing
it they might as well like they they're
ignoring the sunken cost fallacy and
they're just like we gotta just try
again maybe we were too early we'll just
ship the thing now and see if people
want it this time I don't know tough to
say here's a conclusion if you are such
a fan of Apple products and sound
quality that you want to hear exactly
how bad Siri is and Crystal Clear high
definition Dolby Atmos even
then this is a smart speaker for you but
for everyone else there's still the
homepod mini and for everyone else there
are other options from Google and Amazon
that are frankly much better smart
speakers not Samsung though that Bixby
smart speaker straight up never came out
don't think I forgot about that Samsung
so you know we know Siri sucks but at
least Siri sucks seamlessly on a smart
speaker that sounds pretty sweet
thanks for watching
catch you the next one
foreign
[Music]